معكم الان هذه الصور المباشره من العاصفه
من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس واخرى كذلك من
مدينه تيرين
لتين تشهدان احتجاجات متواصله ما يسمى
بالخميس الاسود وقد جاء ذلك ربما احتجاجا
على حديث الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
عن قانون اصلاح التقاعد لقى لقت هذه
التصريحات ردود فعل غاضبه
ومندد وذلك بعد حديث للمره الاولى له منذ
اندلاع على احتجاجات بعد اصراره على تطبيق
اصلاح نظام التقاعد
ماكرون شدده على اهميه دخول هذا المشروع
لحيز التنفيذ بحلول نهايه العام معتبرا
بانه ضروري وذلك في مقابله تلفزيونيه
نشاهد الان هذه الاحتجاجات في الشوارع
الفرنسيه ما زالت وربما الاعداد ستزيد
كذلك خلال الساعات القادمه
وايضا هناك تجهيز من النقابات اليوم
لاضراب عام لتظاهرات في تحرك
وصفته وسائل الاعلام بانه الخميس الاسود
[موسيقى]